now look at your page and compare it to
the design mock and make sure that you
go deeper than just a simple visual
check see if the defining parts are
correct the layout margins fonts colors
etc for example does the image in the
mock-up look different than the image on
your page in comparing the two you can
see that there's actually a space here
and we don't have a space here you can
use dev tools to find the proper value
of the margin for the image class once
you've refined it in dev tools you can
then save it to your CSS file you can
look to the design mock to find this
information the background and color for
the title is also incorrect
now often these colors are provided
within the design document and you can
see these small boxes on the left hand
side and the color in a hex code is
defined there but you can also use
different color picker tools to get the
same information as you refine the
design answer the following questions
first what margin size gets the design
closer to the mock also what is the
background color for the header